la finance fin de journée les durs avec
nous mais faites moi confiance quelques
minutes
en fait la finance c'est terriblement
simple pendant 30 ans je me suis occupé
de risques financiers et j'ai notamment
été pendant six ans comité de direction
générale d'une banque et j'ai acquis une
conviction très forte que je voudrais
partager avec vous ce soir c'est que les
grandes banques
gangréné par la finance de marché sont
devenus des dangers publics et que c'est
notre responsabilité à tous deux
citoyens de les ramener vers l'intérêt
général alors la seule chose à bien
comprendre au départ c'est la différence
entre la banque traditionnelle et la
finance de marché la banque
traditionnelle c'est celle qu'on connaît
look on sent des crédits elles tiennent
aux comptes
c'est une organisation d'intérêt général
d'abord parce qu'il faut que le banquier
défend notre intérêt avant le sien on
n'y connaît rien ou pas grand chose
ensuite parce que il faut que la
collectivité protège les banques
une banque qui fait faillite c'est nos
économies qui partent dans l'évier mais
ça peut être toute l'économie qui part
et donc c'est une activité d'intérêt
général la finance de marché c'est un
petit bout de la finance certains
l'appellent la spéculation financière
mais il ya en tout cas deux choses sur
la première c'est que ça n'est pas une
activité d'intérêt général et la
deuxième c'est que c'est une activité
extrêmement dangereuse alors on comprend
facilement pourquoi une activité typique
de la finance de marché c'est j'emprunte
pour acheter des actions en espérant
qu'elles vont monter et puis
malheureusement elle s'effondre j'arrive
pas à m'en débarrasser
je suis ruinée je peux pas rembourser
mon ancrage fait faillite c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé en 1930
quand un certain nombre de banques qui
avaient des activités de marché ont fait
faillite et les pouvoirs publics partout
dans le monde ont pris une décision
simple l on dit
lui de finance de marché dans les
banques en gros on va pas risquer une
activité d'intérêt général avec des
activités dangereuses pendant d'état
d'année ça a bien marché
et puis il y a une trentaine d'années on
a inventé un certain nombre de nouveaux
produits financiers qui ont complètement
dynamité toutes les contraintes qu'il y
avait sur la spéculation
par exemple avant il fallait attendre
quand même plusieurs heures pour
spéculer acheter et revendre désormais
on a pu spéculer sur une seconde même
sur une fraction de seconde on a pu
acheter vendre
deuxième exemple avant devaient spéculer
sur des produits financiers réels
maintenant on peut inventer des produits
financiers c'est à dire par exemple
avoir des barils de pétrole virtuel
qu'on va pouvoir créer autant qu'on
voudra les banquiers ont vu ce potentiel
ils sont tout sauf idéaux ils sont venus
revoir les pouvoirs publics ils auront
dit regardez il ya un potentiel
faramineux c'est dangereux il faut que
ce soit des gens gros et sérieux comme
nous les banques qui s'en occupe
sinon ça va être un bain de sang et les
pouvoirs publics un peu partout se sont
laissés convaincre et donc la finance de
marché est revenue au coeur des banques
et à partir de là pendant 30 ans
les banques ont développé de façon
fantastique cette activité en y mettant
tous leurs moyens
et souvenons nous que ce sont quand même
les organisations privées les plus
puissantes de la planète
le résultat de ce développement
fantastique 4 conséquences négatives
pour nous c'est très coûteux
c'est inutile ces temps dangereux et
c'est parfaitement immoral
alors je lis reprend rapidement une par
une c'est très coûteux alors on le sait
on dit oui c'est coûteux ah oui les
financiers sont payés comme des joueurs
de foot professionnels bon c'est vrai
enfin une équipe de foot jusqu'à nouvel
ordre c'est onze joueurs dans l'équipe
d'une grande banque
vous pouvez avoir onze mille joueurs
deuxième élément en général les
footballeurs se contentent pour jouer
d'un ballon de foot
nos joueurs de marché ont besoin
d'ordinateur extraordinairement
tout est donc on arrive à quelque chose
de gigantesque mans coûteux et c'est
nous qui le payons
alors vous vous dites non écoutez moi en
tout cas j'ai jamais acheté de ces trucs
là et vous tromper parce que en fait
c'est pas nous qui les achetons mais
c'est les entreprises et nous achetons
les produits des entreprises et donc
indirectement c'est exactement comme la
publicité qu'on finit évidemment par
payer comme consommateur nous payons
tous ces onze mille joueurs avec leurs
ordinateurs et les bonus de leurs chefs
c'est très coûteux c'est inutile
il exagère peut pas faire un truc aussi
énorme qu'ils soient inutiles
arrêtons-nous une seconde sur comment
fonctionne la spéculation mon exemple de
tout à l'heure j'ai acheté des actions
l'ennemi du spéculateur c'est la
stabilité des prix
pourquoi parce que j'ai acheté mon
action et ça bouge pas woods six mois
n'a pas bougé j'ai rien gagné j'ai rien
perdu mais il faut que je paye mes onze
mille joueurs et leur ordinateur je suis
ruinée et donc depuis 30 ans
toute l'intelligence de la finance s'est
développée sur un objectif faire bouger
les prix à chaque minute à chaque
seconde
peu importe le sens et vous avez bien
remarqué que les prix tous les prix
bougent frénétiquement sur les marchés
alors pour y arriver il ya les méthodes
à l'ancienne
la rumeur alors la rumeur c'est le
pétrole va monter à non il va descendre
à b va remonter où il sera là dans trois
mois il sera là dans deux jours il sera
là dans une heure et donc c'est devenu
une industrie en soit il ya des méthodes
beaucoup plus moderne sophistiqué
informatique on balance sur les marchés
des dizaines des centaines de milliers
d'ordres par ordinateur qui donne
l'impression qu' un mouvement tard il ya
un mouvement on y va et puis il ya cent
mille ordre dans l'autre sens qu'ils
disent à raison non finalement ça
descend et donc le résultat tout ça à
chaque fois vous voyez bouger des prix
vous dites c'est arbitraire ça sert à
rien non ça sert à quelque chose
chaque mouvement de prix dégage des
profits problème nous nos entreprises
l'économie réelle on n'aime pas quand
les prix bougent
hélas la finance de marché arrive avec
une
ovation génial en disant attendez j'ai
inventé des produits qui vont un peu
vous protéger contre les mouvements de
prix vous voyez bien j'étais utile
finalement mais ce qu'il faut leur dire
c'est leur dire ok on est dans un bateau
et vous secouer le bateau comme un
prunier
on a le mal de mer et vous nous vendez
un produit contre le mal de mer mais si
vous arrêtiez de secouer le bateau on
n'aurait pas le mal de mer et on
n'aurait pas besoin de tous vos produits
anti mal de mer donc c'est très coûteux
ça sert à rien et c'est dangereux parce
que à force de secouer un bateau il
finit par couler on a mis du temps à
s'en rendre compte parce que la finance
a inventé une histoire absolument
incroyable elle a réussi à faire croire
à tout le monde que plus il y avait des
spéculateurs qui en étaient en sécurité
comment est-ce qu'ils y sont arrivés
alors ils ont employé des tas de mots
très compliqué mais ils sont repartis
finalement de mon petit exemple de tout
à l'heure le spéculateur qui a acheté
vivi villa baisse il arrive par vendre
et donc ils ont expliqué avec des mots
beaucoup plus compliqué il parlait de
liquidités notamment
ils ont dit oui s'il ya quelques
spéculateurs isolé c'est la catastrophe
mais s'il ya des milliers de
spéculateurs adossés à des banques ayant
les poches presque infinies et bien
d'autres spéculateurs coincé il trouvera
immédiatement en face de lui un autre
spéculateurs qu'ils eurent achètera ses
actions ils ont donc réussi à nous faire
croire que le bateau serait d'autant
plus en sécurité qui auraient de
gentilles secoue ses faramineux mais ça
a marché
et ça a été face à un monde financier
incrédule qu'on a vu arriver la crise de
2007 2008 qui s'est produit comme toutes
les autres crises depuis 500 ans c'est à
dire qu'en gros on a découvert que quand
une bulle éclate tout le monde pense la
même chose
c'est à dire que ça va tomber comme une
pierre et que donc à ce moment là vous
pouvez avoir un 10000 spéculateurs
personne n'en veut de vos actions et
donc évidemment la crise s'est produite
avec deux différences malheureusement
avec les crises habituel la première
c'est que évidemment puisqu'il y avait
plus de spéculateurs elle était plus
grosse et la deuxième c'est que les
spéculateurs étaient des banques et donc
nous nous sommes trouvés nos états et
puis nous derrière les contribuables
nous nous sommes retrouvés dans la
situation extrêmement désagréable
d'avoir à sauver les spéculateurs
parce que personne ne pouvait se
permettre de voir les banques allé au
tapis
donc c'est coûteux c'est inutile c'est
dangereux mais le plus grave à mon sens
c'est que c'est parfaitement immoral le
développement faramineux de la finance
de marché à mener au développement de
ces entre guillemets valeur c'est-à-dire
l'idée qu'on peut gagner en une journée
autant qu'en une année de travail dans
un hôpital l'idée que des écarts de
salaire de 1 à 100 c'est tout à fait
normal
l'idée de plus on alimente en crédit
mieux c'est et ces idées là cette idée
aussi que l'on peut tricher pendant des
années et ne pas aller en prison ont
détruit une partie de notre tissu social
et une part de la montée de l'extrémisme
le dégoût dans le politique
une part de cette dissolution finalement
d'un certain nombre de valeurs qui nous
font tenir ensemble est largement due à
la finance de marché et un symbole de
tout ça c'est les banques qui étaient
avant des organismes relativement
crédible et en qui on pouvait avoir
confiance
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas un trimestre
sentier un scandale dans une banque
et ce n'est pas moins qu'il dit je
prends le principal quotidien financier
européen qui s'appelle le financiel
times et sont meilleurs éditorialistes
s'appelle martin wolf
qu'est ce qu'il nous dit martin wolf il
ya quelques semaines les élites
financières d'aujourd'hui sont avides
incompétente et irresponsable la banque
la plus prestigieuse entre guillemets du
monde de la finance appel goldman sachs
ses dirigeants sont fabuleusement payer
leur rémunération leur bonus dépend du
résultat de la vente
et cette année catastrophe la banque a
été prise la main dans le sac dans une
vilaine affaire
en trichant contre ses clients elle a eu
une très grosse amende
son résultat a chuté que pensez vous qu
on fait les dirigeants de goldman sachs
bien ils ont traficoter a posteriori les
règles de leur rémunération pour
maintenir leurs bonus
malgré la baisse du résultat à vie d'
incompétent irresponsable je suis
convaincu que dans quelques années nos
petits enfants n'arriveront pas
comprendre comment toute une génération
a pu dépenser autant d'intelligence sur
une activité aussi nuisible car à partir
de là que faire eh bien je crois qu'on
peut appeler à une transition financière
exactement comme il ya une transition
énergétique
il ya trop de carbone sur la planète
mais il ya aussi trop de finances sur la
planète et donc quelle est la première
mesure à prendre pour la transition
financière c'est tout bêtement de
corriger l'erreur faite il y a trente
ans faire ressortir la finance de marché
des banques avec deux mesures immédiates
de conséquences immédiates
premièrement la banque pourra se
reconcentrer
ce qui est sûr ce qui aurait dû toujours
être sa mission jouer avec son client et
pas jouer contre son client et la
deuxième conséquence c'est que la
finance de marché sortant de la banque
ne sera plus protégé par la grande
banque elle même protégé par nous les
contribuables
elle sera tout seul dans la nature comme
un plombier un boulanger un charcutier
pouvant faire faillite étant très
attention et elle redeviendra comme il
ya trente ans beaucoup plus prudente
elle deviendra elle disparaîtra pas elle
deviendra un bonsaï de finance de marché
et on aime bien les petites choses elle
redeviendra sympathique donc bien sûr ce
ne sera pas facile mais si nous y
croyons
si nous demandons dans nos associations
dans nos réseaux sociaux si nous
demandons a évidemment nos hommes et nos
femmes politiques
cette transition financière
le climat est bon désormais pour
l'obtenir
nous pouvons si nous l'exigeons tous
obtenir la transition financière et si
malgré tout certains soirs vous avez un
moment de doute que vous avez besoin
d'une bouffée d'optimisme
je conclurai en vous recommandant mon
propre remède qui est de revoir le film
merveilleux de frank capra qui s'appelle
la vie est belle
c'est probablement un des films
humanistes les plus bouleversants qu'on
puisse voir et aussi c'est la plus belle
description de ce que peut être une
bonne banque c'est-à-dire une banque qui
ne divise pas une collectivité mais au
contraire une banque qui soudent
ensemble une collectivité
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]